bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors les annonces
des manuels mâcon en tant qu'hôtelier
vous en avez pensé quoi est-ce que ça
vous a permis et d'y voir plus clair
vous avez entendu mon hôtel iker madame
je vous je me fais provocateur on n'a
même pas parlé des hôteliers on passe au
travers de la raquette tout le temps on
n'a jamais été fermé nous on n'a pas de
clients on a pas de transport les gens
ne se déplacent pas mais les hôtels ne
sont pas fermées administrativement
donc je pense qu'il vaut mieux être dans
un monastère aujourd'hui au moins on à
la prière ensemble parce que les hôtels
les clients y rentrer dans les chambres
ils ont pas le droit d'aller au
restaurant ils n'ont pas droit à la
salle de petit déjeuner et c'est tout
donc on doit faire la moitié des hôtels
sur le fermé en france ceux qui sont
ouverts s'ils font dispensant
d'occupation c'est un maximum c'est un
scandale
aujourd'hui on se cacher son petit doigt
on va d confiner le 15
les jambes alors dire vous allez pouvoir
aller la montagne les stations de ski
moi qui suis lyonnais on est on verra
bien on est auvergne et rhône-alpes est
la première destination touristique
c'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas mis les
remontées mécaniques en route que les
gens vont pas aller à la montagne
donc au lieu d'organiser les choses on
va les subir et moi ce dont j'ai peur
c'est de la troisième vague du fait
on est tous tous tous tout le monde le
sait que le coc vivent ils se
transmettent par et voire familial
amical donc aujourd'hui les restaurants
les hôtels ont des protocoles stricts
il vaut mieux manger pour si on est
douze fois l'ol ils vont aller manger
dans deux tables de 6 au restaurant que
de manger ce soir parce que la
grand-mère elle va vouloir prendre ses
petits-enfants dans les bras elle m'a
aussi ça la vaisselle et toucher les
d'affaires que tout le monde attend
cometti je suis je dit pas avec la
grand-mère qui fasse la vaisselle mais
tout le monde va toucher tout et les
protocoles ne sont pas respectées nous
on a des protocoles stricts et ils sont
pas meilleurs que ceux des cantines des
internats qui heureux de retravailler
que le restaurant du sénat qui lui a
droit de travailler la restauration
collective elle doit travailler notre
restauration à nour et les bannis c'est
pas possible
vous disiez un pas de fermeture
administrative pour les hôtels mais bon
c'est quand même difficile
de rester ouvert en plein confinement
quels ont été les effets du deuxième
confinement sur les réservations
nos prévisions elle était de 15% des
hôtels qui déposerait le bilan avec le
premier confinement on va passer à 30
avec le 2ème confinement aujourd'hui on
n'a plus de fonds propres
on peut tenir tout ce qu'on veut mais je
vous dis on est toujours au travers de
la raquette comme la lgv vous avez
entendu présent la république hier alors
monsieur le maire s'est exprimé ce matin
en disant on va prouver quelque chose
pour les hôtels mais pour autant on
parle jamais de nous il n'ya pas plus
parler des discothèques qui elles elles
sont responsables de rien elles sont
fermées depuis le 17 mars
vous voyez cet ensemble qui fait qu' on
peut contenir les gens qu'on a des
protocoles qui ont été validés par plus
pas moins que les commerçants je veux
dire les commerçants les soutiens pour
qu'ils ouvrent mais vous allez faire vos
courses sans pouvoir manger un plat du
jour à midi c'est pas possible
donc à partir du 15e demande que les
restaurants comme ça avait été fait dans
les grandes villes avant le confinement
ouvre sous couvre-feu jusqu'à 21h pour
faire manger les gens aiment évident d
avec des protocoles qui sont qui ont
fait leurs preuves
donnez nous des études sur les clusters
des restaurants à sia pas y'a pas alors
il ya certains hôtels même pas fermée
administrativement qui ont quand même dû
fermer pendant les périodes de
confinement est ce que vous savez si
certains hôtels ont dû fermer
définitivement et mettre la clé sous la
porte
aujourd'hui les bilans sont pas encore
sortis jeudi à le confiner au lac par
des hôtels dans leur bilan qui va du 1er
janvier au 31 décembre
donc pour l'instant on est en suspension
avec une prise en charge de notre valeur
ajoutée que sont nos salariés par le
chômage partiel qui coûte quand même 15
% aux entreprises parce que tous les le
chômage partiel
après les congés payés qui va falloir
donner pour lequel on n'aura pas la
trésorerie les tgs durcissent de plus en
plus quand on vit il a dit hier les 20%
ces précieux pour les périodes de
chiffre d'affaires lorsque les gens ont
été fermées administrativement
les hôtels ont choisi de se fermer à par
douze départements qui l'avait fait dans
la première vague donc les hôtels qui
nous il n'y a pas de mesures
administratives pour l'instant ils n'ont
droit à rien
merci en tout cas d'avoir été en direct
avec nous sur rtl france monsieur diouf
je rappelle que vous êtes hôtelier à
lyon et président de l'union des métiers
et des industries de l'hôtellerie merci